la llamada además se produce el mismo
día que está prevista una reunión entre
el presidente ruso vladimir putin y el
líder húngaro viktor orbán hay
preocupación por cómo puede afectar esta
reunión a la unidad europea pero a quien
quien lo que se considera más importante
es que rusia y eeuu sigan dialogando
para intentar rebajar la tensión en
europa del estero el kremlin ha pedido
garantías materiales de seguridad sobre
todo ha exigido que la otan garantice
que jamás va a admitir a ucrania como
miembro la conversación de blinken y
lávrov será el primer diálogo directo
entre los dos principales diplomáticos
de ambos países desde que washington
presentó sus respuestas por escrito a
las demandas de seguridad que hizo moscú